10 قتلى في صفوف المحتاجين الايرانيين
خلال 24 ساعه والمعارضه تلتقي البرلمان
الاوروبي اليوم
ولي العهد السعودي يلتقي رئيس كوريا
الجنوبيه وتوقيع اتفاقيات مع سهول بقيمه
29 مليار دولار تشمل الطاقه النظيفه
والتكنولوجيا الطبيه
للازمه الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
طبتم مطابقه اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى نشره
اخباريه من العربيه نبداها مع هذا الخبر
قالت منظمته والكرديه لحقوق الانسان عندما
لا يقل عن عشره اشخاص قتلوا بنيران الامن
الايراني في مدن
بمحافظه كردستان
بمحافظه اذربيجان الغربيه خلال الساعات ال
24 الماضيه كما تحدثت وسائل الاعلام
الايرانيه عن مقتل اثنين من قوه الباسيج
واصابه سبعه من عناصر الشرطه في اطلاق نار
بمدينه اصفهان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اكبر
الله مصطلحاته يستخدمها النظام الايراني
لوصف المتظاهرين في الانتفاضه الحاليه في
كل يوم يزداد فيه زخم الاحتجاجات تزيد
وحشيه رد فعل النظام
تكتيكات جديده تتبعها قوه الامن اخرها
مسيرات تحلق على علو منخفض فوق رؤوس
المتظاهرين وتفتح النيران عليهم
[تصفيق]
اما في محطه المترو التي تعتبر من نقاط
الاحتجاج الساخنه كان الرصاص قوات الامن
كفيلا ببث الذعر والتدافع بين المتظاهرين
لم يسلم حرم الجامعه الطالب
[موسيقى]
من ساحات الاحتجاج الى المعتقل ومن مواجهه
العنف الى التهم الجاهزه قد يكون مصير
المتظاهرين الاعدام القضاء الايراني
[موسيقى]
مشاهد ليست جديده فالتاريخ يكرر نفسه بما
يشبه احتجاجات نوفمبر 2019
والتي تسببت بمقتل اكثر من 1000 شخصا
واعتقال الالاف الا ان ساحه العنف في
الاحتجاجات الحاليه اوسع الى عمر العربيه
بان الاحزاب الايرانيه المعارضه من بينهم
ممثلين عن ثلاثه ائتلافات مهمه ستجتمع مع
البرلمان الاوروبي في بروكسل في 17 من
الشهر الجاري لمناقشه الاحتجاجات الجاريه
ومستقبل الاوضاع في ايران
في موضوع متعلق بايران ولكن من بريطانيا
قال رئيس جهاز المخابرات الداخليه
البريطانيه كين مالكوم ان طهران خططت
الاغتيال هو خط فيما لا يقل عن 10 من
المقيمين على الاراضي البريطانيه
تتهممهم بانهم اعدائهم النظام
وروسيا والصينيه
خارجيه تواجهها بريطانيا
رئيس جهاز استخباراتها الداخليه بثلاث
مناطق جغرافيه اذا حذر من ان ايران تخطط
لاستهداف من تعتبرهم اعداء نظامها على
الاراضي البريطانيه هذا التحذير جاء بعد
اسبوع من استدعاء الخارجيه البريطانيه
للقائم باعمال السفاره الايرانيه للتاكيد
على ان بريطانيا لن تتسامح بتهديد او
ترهيب حياه اي شخص على اراضيها ايران
العدوانيه وهذا التهديد يشمل في اقصى
درجاته
في خطابه السنوي عن التهديدات قال مكلم ان
بريطانيا ستضطر الى مواجهه العدوان
الروسيه المتزايد لسنوات قادمه مضيفا ان
روسيا تنفذ هجمات الكترونيه وعمليه تظليل
وتجسس وتتدخل في العمليه الديمقراطيه في
بريطانيا
رفضنا لاسباب تتعلق بالامن القومي اكثر من
100 طلب تاشيره دبلوماسيه روسيه ونعمل
لجعل المملكه المتحده اصعب بيئه عمل ممكنه
للانشطه السريه الروسيه
اما الصين فتوصل سعيها للتاثير على
سياسيين واشخاص في وقت مبكر من حياتهم
وبحسب مكلم فهي تستخدم كل الوسائل المتاحه
لمراقبه والترهيب الشتات الصيني ولاعاده
بعض مواطنها قصرا في ما محليا لا يزال
الارهاب المستوحى من الايديولوجيه
الاسلاميه المتطرفه يمثل حوالي ثلاثه
ارباع قضايا الارهاب مع تسجيل تزايد في
محاولات اليمين المتطرف للحصول على
الاسلحه الناريه وتاجيج المظالم وتضخيم
نظريات المؤامره
عن هذه التهديدات ياتي في سياق التقييمه
للاوضاع الامنيه والمخاطر الداخليه
والخارجيه وهي محاوله لطمئنه الراي العام
هنا ان الاجهزه الامنيه مدركه للتحديات
التي تواجهها بريطانيا لكنها محاوله قد
تكون صعبه وسط تزايد المخاطر النجمه عن
التطورات السياسيه
اكد تم هوكنز المتحدث باسم الاسطول الخامس
للعربيه ان الولايات المتحده جاهزه
لمواجهه التهديدات الايرانيه في المنطقه
واوضح ان مشاركه المعلومات التي تتم مع
شركاء تقوم على بناء الثقه وتقويه
العلاقات فيما بينهما
القوات المشتركه وهي الاكبر في العالم
ولدينا تحالف اخر وهو التحالف الذي يعنى
بخفر السواحل وهو مؤلف من عشر دول هذه
التحالفات ملتزمه بالحفاظ على مضيق هرمز
وباب المنزل وسنستمر بتعزيز وتوسيع تلك
الشركات على المصاب الاقليمي وتقديم الرد
على المطلوب وكذلك اعاده الطمانينه بشان
الشحن التجاري بمعنى اننا ملتزمون بالحفاظ
على حريه الملاحه البحريه والتجاره
العالميه يجب ان نكون اكثر تاهبا وان
نعيرا انتباها كبيرا لاي انشطه تزعزع
للسقراء وخاصه في مناطق المياه المحيطه
وهذا ما نفعله
افاد مكتبه رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه بان
الرئيس يونسول سيجري محادثات مع ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان الذي وصل
الى صول ثاني محطات جولته الاسيويه وكانت
باستقباله رئيسه وزراء كوريا الجنوبيه
وعقد الامير محمد بن سلمان فور وصوله جلسه
مباحثات مع رئيس الوزراء الكوري
الجنوبيه تناول خلالها افاق التعامل
الثنائيه وسبل تنميه وتعزيز في مجالات
مختلفه ومن المنتظر ان تكون الملفات
الاقتصاديه الكبرى على جدول الزياره بحضور
كبرى الشركات الكوريه ورجال الاعمال وذلك
لمناقشه فرص الاستثمار في السعوديه
وزير الاستثمار السعوديه خالد الفالح قال
انه تم توقيعه 26 اتفاقيه مع سئل بقيمه 29
مليار دولار خلال زياره ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان لكوريا الجنوبيه
واشار الفالح الى ان التوقيع على مشروع
شاهين بقيمه خمسه مليارات دولار يعد اكبر
استثمارا اجنبيه في كوريا وقال الفالح ان
الصندوق صندوق الاستثمارات العامه يوقع
عددا من الاتفاقيات مع شركات كوريا جنوبيه
60 عاما عمرو علاقات السعوديه وكوريا
الجنوبيه جمعتهما توافقات عده في الكثير
من الجوانب السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والثقافيه فمنذ نشاتها في العام
1962 كان للبلدين محطات مهمه اقتصاديا
وتجاريا حيث شهدت العلاقات المشتركه منذ
بدايتها اتفاقيات ومذكرات تفاهم اسهم في
جعل السعوديه من اوائل الشركاء التجاريين
لكوريا الجنوبيه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
حيث كان من اهمها تاسيس اللجنه السعوديه
الكوريه المشتركه فيما شكل اطلاق رؤيه
السعوديه الكوريه 20 30 في العام 2017
نقطه تحول مهمه لتاسيس مرحله شراك اكبر في
قطاعات الاستراتيجيه منها النقل والطاقه
والاتصالات حيث تستهدف كوريا الجنوبيه من
خلالها ان تكون من ابرز الشركاء المساهمين
في تحقيق رؤيه السعوديه 2030
في العام 20 21 بلغ حجم التبادل التجاري
بين السعوديه وكوريا الجنوبيه نحو 26
مليار دولار في ما سجل الميزان التجاري
فائضا لصالح السعوديه بقيمه 19 مليار
دولار
وعلى الصعيد الاستثمارات تعمل شركه سعوديه
مختلفه في السوق الكوريه من ابرزها
استثمار ارامكو السعوديه حيث تعمل من
خلالها اربعه مشاريع وشركتين تتجاوز
قيمتها الخمس مليارات دولار وايضا سابق
تعمل بحجم استثمارات بلغ مليار دولار
وفي الجهه المقابله بلغ عدد الاستثمارات
الكوريه في السعوديه
132 استثمارا باجمالي راس المال يتجاوز
ثلاث مليارات في قطاعات منها التعدين
والكهرباء والغاز
زياره ولي العهد السعودي ستشهد توقيع
اتفاقيات وشركات مع شركات كوريه والسعوديه
في مختلف المجالات مع توقعاتنا بجذب
المزيد من الاستثمارات الكوريه الى
المملكه ميسون ويهد العربيه سول كوريا
الجنوبيه
فلا رئيسه هيئه الاركان الامريكيه الجنرال
مايك ميلي ان احتمال دفعه اوكرانيا روسيا
للانسحابي من اراضيها
واستبعد قدرته اوكرانيا على الانتصار
حاليا كما اكد ميلي انه يشجعوا على الحل
السياسي
واضاف رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه ان
روسيا تحتفظ بقدرات قتاليه موازينا داخل
اوكرانيا وبالحديث عن المفاوضات قال مالي
ان الرئيس
اوكرانيا تملك توقيت وشكل المفاوضات مع
روسيا
نفى الرئيس الاوكرانيه بلو ديمير زلنيسكي
ان يكون صاروخ الذي سقط في بولندا من
اطلاق قوهته ودعا زلانسكي الى تمكين بلاده
من زياره الموقع وطلب بتزويدها بتفاصيل
التحقيق في الحادث ياتي هذا فيما دعت
موسكو بولندا لوقف ما وصفته بالمزايدات
المعاديه لروسيا
التقرير المسائي الذي قدمه لقائد القوه
الجويه شخصيا وكذلك الى القائد العام ليس
لدي شك في انه لم يكن صاروخنا ليس لدي اي
سبب لشك بهم فنحن نخوض الحرب معا من فضلكم
دعونا نزور الموقع سيكون هذا عادلا اعتقد
انه من حقنا ان نكون هناك
هذه النشره مستمره فيها بعد الفاصل
فرق الاطفاء تسيطر على حريق اندلع في مطار
بغداد
حياكم الله قال السفير الفرنسيه لدى اليمن
جمبري سافا انه بحث مع وزير الخارجيه
اليمنيه احمد عوض بن مبارك الاربعاء الوضع
في البلاد في اعقابي الهجمات التي شنتها
جماعه الحوثي على موانئها يمنيه واضاف صاف
ان هناك قلق لدى فرنسا من تجاوزات
الحوثيين تجاه النساء والاطفال وموظفي
الدوله وحريه التعبير في المناطق الخاضعه
لسيطرتهم داعيا الى احترام الحقوق
الاساسيه في اليمن واشار صافا الى ان
بلاده تؤكد مجددا دعمها لمجلس القياده
السياسيه والحكومه في جهودهما لاستعاده
دوله تعمل من اجل خدمه جميع اليمني
انتشر وباء في تعز بشكل كبير خصوصا في
المناطق التي تكثر فيها او يكثر فيها
البعوض والسدود المائيه المكشوفه ما فاقما
من معاناه الاف اليمنيين وتستقبل
المستشفيات المدينه يوميا عشرات الحالات
المرضيه المصابه بحمى الضنك والحمى
الفيروسيه والملاريا بعضها دخلت في
مضاعفات خطره يتطلب نقلها الى العنايه
المركزه وتعاني مئات الحالات المصابه
بالمرض جراء رد الوضع الصحي في المدينه
وانعدام الادويه والمستلزمات الطبيه بسبب
الحصار الذي تفرضه الملكشيات الحوثيه على
تعز
بمراره هنا قضاء ايضا في طوارئ المشفى وهو
يحاول التغلب على وباء حمى الضنك لكنه بدى
اليوم محظوظ عن غيره صيام الذين ساءت
حالتهم فتوجب على الاطباء وضعهم تحت
الرعايه الصحيه المركزه في هذه الغرف
المغلقه
بسرعه
اعداد المصابين بالحميه في تعز الى اكثر
من احد عشر الف حاله في هذا العام لا هيك
عم فقدت حياتهم نتيجه الوباء
50 الى 70 حاله يوميا من الحميات
كانت
الملاريا جميع انواع الحميات تاتيلها
مستشفى
[موسيقى]
في مدينه تعز اكثر من 11,000 حاله منذ
بدايه العام حتى اليوم
ينظم هذه الحالات طبعا سجلت خلال الشهور
الثلاثه همم
اغسطس وسيبتمبر واكتوبر وايضا هناك 15
حاله وفاه
اتساع رقعه انتشار الوباء في المدينه هذه
طاقم من معاناه السكان بلوجع على المدينه
تعيش في كارثه صحيه مع انعدام الادويه
وافتقار المستشفيات لابسط المستلزمات
الطبيه في ظل حصار الميليشيات المطبق على
المدينه منذ سنين وما ترد الوضع الصحي في
المدينه تزداد اذا نسبه الاصابه بالحميات
سيما حمى الضنك الذي اثقل كاهل المواطنين
في هذه المدينه فالمستشفيات هذه تستقبل
العشرات يوميا من هذه الحاله ال سعيد
العربيه تعز
قال المبعوث الامميه الى ليبيا عبد الله
باتيلي انه دعم مجددا كافه القيادات
الليبيه للعمل معا لتسريع عمليه السياسيه
والذهاب نحو الانتخابات ووضع البلاد على
مسار السلام والاستقرار واضاف باتيلي على
تويتر انه جاء اجرى مباحثات وصفها
بالمثمره مع رئيس مجلس النواب اللي يبيع
عقيل صالح في مدينه القبه وقال بيان لمجلس
النواب الليبي ان اللقاء اتناولت تطورات
الاوضاع السياسيه والامنيه في البلاد
وكيفيه الخروج من حال الانسداد السياسي او
الدفع بالمسارين السياسي والاملي واضاف
البيان ان الجانبين ناقش ايضا المسار
الدستوريه وسبل الوصول بالبلاد الى
الانتخابات في اقرب وقت ممكن وتهيئه
الظروف الملائمه لذلك
انا الرئيس جوبيدن الجمهوريين بفوزهم
بالاغلبيه في مجلس النواب الامريكي معربا
عن استعداده للتعاون معهم من اجل خدمه
الشعب الامريكي وقال ايضا ان الشعب
الامريكي يريدون ان نقوم بانجازات من اجله
واكد ايضا انه سيعمل مع اي كان سواء من
الديمقراطيين او الجمهوريين لتحقيق نتائج
لهم
قال زعيم الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب كيف
المكارسي بعد ان تزع حزمه وسيطر على مجلس
النواب في الكونغرس انه يريد احداث
التغيير للشعب الامريكي وغرد مكارثي على
تويتر قائلا ان الجمهوريين سيطروا على
مجلس النواب رسميا وان الامريكيين مستعدون
لاتجاه جديد
والجمهوريون في مجلس النواب مستعدون
لتحقيق ذلك
كما اعاد الاعضاء الجمهوريون في مجلس
الشيوخ انتخاب ماتش ماكونال زعيم للاقليه
الجمهوريه وقال ماكونيلا في تغريده له على
تويتر انه لا شرف لي اعاده انتخابي من قبل
زملاء الجمهوريين لقياده الحزب في مجلس
الشيوخ مشيرا الى ان الحسبه موحد ومليء
بالطاقه والافكار واكد ماكونال في تغريده
على محاربه ما اسماء بتهور الديمقراطيين
وانه سيعمل وفريقه على تعزيز وتحسين حياه
العائلات امريكا قويه
كل ذلك في ظل توالي ردود الافعال بعد
اعلان الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام
ترشحن احدث جدلا واسعا داخل الحزب
الجمهوري
[تصفيق]
اعلن الرئيس الامريكي
2024 لكن الطريقه لذلك صعبه في ظل منافسه
قويه من داخل الحزب الجمهوريه مع سطوع نجم
حاكم
نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه التي وصفت
بالضعيفه وملفات قضائيه تواجهه ترامب
اقل من 50 في المئه هناك نجوم صعيدون منهم
حيث خسر مرشحوه واكتشف الجمهوريون انه كان
يجمع الاموال الظاهريه
على نفسه
كما ان انتقاداتي بعض الجمهوريين لترامب
ومطالبه بعضهم بالمضيق قدما بعيدا عنه
تشير الى انقسام داخل الحزب حوله ما يعني
انه قد لا يحظى بدعم كل الجمهوريين
ليست مرتفعه هناك الثباتيه الرابحه ضده
بالفعل لكن في الوقت نفسه هناك كثير من
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين قلقون بشان ما
يعنيه ذلك بالنسبه للبلد
ابرزوا ما قد يواجهوا ترامب هو ما كشفت
عنه صحيفه نيويورك تايمز من ان مستشارين
لاداره بيد يعملون على استراتيجيه لكيفيه
رد البيت الابيض على هجماته على الاداره
والتي كانت واضحه في خطاب اعلان الترشح
ترشح ترامب الان يختلفوا عن مكانها عليه
عام 2015 ففي ذلك الوقت كان ينظر اليه كان
رجل اعمال ونجمه تلفزيونيه اعطوا وعودا
كثيره لاصلاح ما وصفه ان ذلك بالفساد اما
الان فهو رئيس سابق يواجه ملاحقات قانونيه
الحسين الطاوض العربيه
افاده مصادر عسكريه كوريه جنوبيه
اطلقت فجر اليوم صاروخان من سواحلها
الشرقيه فيما اعلنت كوريا الشماليه ان رد
فعلها العسكري على التدريبات العسكريه
المشتركه بين الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
سيصبح اكثر غضبا متهمه اياهم بتسعيد
الازمه الامنيه في المنطقه كما قال وزير
الخارجيه كوريا الشماليه في بيان نشرات هو
وكاله الانباء المركزيه الرسميه ان القمه
الثلاثيه التي عقدتها الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه واليابان في الاغنه
الاخيره ستقود الامور في شبه جزيره
الكوريه الى وضعا تتزايد صعوبه التنبؤ به
افاده مراسل العربيه بوقوع حريق داخل مطار
بغداد الدوليه فيما هرع الدفاع المدني
وتمت السيطره على الحريق
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
عشره قتلى في صفوف المحتاجين الايرانيين
خلال 24 ساعه والمعارضه تلتقي البرلمان
الاوروبي اليوم
ولي العهد السعودي يلتقي رئيس كوريا
الجنوبيه وتوقيع اتفاقيات مع سهول بقيمه
29 مليار دولار تشمل الطاقه النظيفه
والتكنولوجيا الطبيه
المزايدات المعاديه لروسيا واشنطن تشجع
على الحل السياسي الى الازمه الى اوكرانيه
اراكم بعد دقائق
[موسيقى]